Chinese team behind Extreme Animal Gene
experiments as it may lead to super
soldiers who survive nuclear fallout
modified human embryonic stem cells
showed Supernatural resistance against
radiation according to a paper by
Academy of military Sciences team in
Beijing shanghai-based scientist says
study may open can of worms particularly
when funding is involved and they show a
water bear there for some reason a
tardigrade now the the uh the funny
thing I just you know this is this was
okay Fallout video games
this is a component of the story that
the writers created for that video game
Fallout is a story where there's a
nuclear war wipes everybody out tons of
people move into vaults and there's
something called the forced evolutionary
virus that attempts to make humans more
resistant to radioactive fallout so they
give people the virus to alter their
genes instead they be they get
sterilized and their brain capacity
diminishes I don't know about whatever
this is all about but it is funny to me
when you see works of fiction
in some fashion be replicated by
scientists and I think it's because uh
people who are writing fiction are
imagining what the future could be like
with the technology we're developing and
these stories persists some fictitious
future a bunch of these guys with
radiation resistance get a hold of the
nuclear weapons and light the world up
so that they're the ones that are left
now you're talking about wrathicon this
they actually embedded tardigrade DNA
into human embryonic stem cells to gain
radiation resistance this is amazing yes
because that's what it was tardigrades
yeah yes I thought it was embryonic stem
cells they put it into embryonic stem
cells the tardigrade jeans and then they
give it to soldiers now you're talking
about Wrath of Khan where in Star Trek
humans genetically engineered themselves
to become better and then the
genetically engineered people said we're
Superior to them and so then the humans
were like we got to get rid of these
super soldiers they're really bad
sentiment outer space froze them
basically I think I may be getting the
story wrong but that's generally the
idea military.com has another very
interesting article that's titled the
future U.S military super soldier may be
closer than we think so these projects
again I I was just speculating that they
probably are in existence and uh they
are so um what year what is this what's
the date on this one we have it right
here
I don't see a date though military.com
is great yeah there's no data on this
though it may not look like the process
that Steve Rogers went through it may be
coming in the next 30 Years
that's it and then there's a famous
saying whatever you think uh the U.S
military has it's usually 30 years
behind for what it already has right now
to be able to breathe underwater like
not have to breathe they'll be able to
see super far at night exactly but but
why do this when we already have the
robot dogs with guns and those Boston
Dynamics robot people because robots
can't secure street corners and they can
get shut down by emps robots robots can
uh perhaps I wonder if they can do a
faraday Shield over some of these robots
that probably would I mean I I don't
they would be pre-programmed a I don't
know how you control them uh if they're
if their signals are are shut down but
yes they can occupy Street Corner yeah
maybe a street corner but they can't
occupy aerial drones can't but robots
can occupy street corners the knights
have a very bright outlook for what
what's coming first of all you're giving
a lot of credit uh there's a movie that
I'm thinking of Idiocracy has anyone
ever seen that yeah
does an experiment where this like like
Average Joe gets frozen for like a
thousand years or something when he
wakes up Society has degraded in such a
fashion that he is the smartest person
on the planet Society is in shambles
they don't know how to farm they're
running out of food they have no water
it's a disaster and their president was
a WWE wrestler exactly and Donald Trump
is in the WWE Hall of Fame
and they're wearing Crocs before Crocs
became popular true yes oh really yes
yes you look at that movie and they were
wearing Crocs I'm terrified we're headed
down a path more likely it's not that
we're headed to we're here
but look Plastics in the water supply
the weird Pharmaceuticals the four
chemicals 12 year olds are getting put
on seed oils the man boobs but but but
but
I I gotta Hammer this point that that
Democrats sterilize their kids abort
their kids they and they so while
they're actively and and they and they
actively argue against having kids so
while they're doing everything in their
power not to have children the right is
having more kids and they're fighting a
culture War over children's education so
my point here is if it were true the
left had unmitigated indoctrination of
children I'd say okay the right's in
trouble your kids are going to get
indoctrinated but if there's a cultural
battle over what's happening in these
schools and you combine the fact that
Democrats are actively trying not to
have kids give it 20 30 years the
country is back on track and I hope so
regarding poisoning of like that you
called a mom forever chemicals pfas pfas
poor floral alkyl stuff they figured out
how to get them out of the soil you hit
it with lasers you convert the soil into
graphene it removes the pfcs the
peripheral oracles it out of the
graphing then you put the graphene back
into the soil it fertilizes the soil and
you've removed the forever chemical huh
this graphene is a big deal yeah it's
21st century steel it's a big deal it'll
be a building with the big deal the
material
lightweight build in space and on Earth
we can make clothing out of it um I'm
not wearing any right now do you have
some graphene clothes yeah shirts there
wow they're really cool in the Heat and
and they keep you warm and I'm sure they
do it's pure car it's just carbon if we
could come back to the point I I think a
lot of this uh genetic manipulation is
essentially governments playing with
god-like power and authority especially
when it comes to creating Super Soul
Soldier babies which obviously has been
happening for a very long time obviously
the Chinese government is doing it but
technology is is really advancing at
such a fast pace that it's going to
outpace our ability to control it and I
think we have already reached a point
where maybe even artificial intelligence
could already be in charge and we might
not even know about it Terminator
exactly but but it's not even a
Terminator like Society it would be a
lot slower and a lot more of human
beings acquiescing to it slowly and
surely that would be a lot more
beneficial for the system to kind of
implement their total control on
everyone and and you got to kind of ask
yourself what are they going to be using
radiation resistant super soldiers for
that that's a question that I think we
should be asking ourselves after looking
at so going to Fallout after the bomb
drops worst case scenario but to go
where you're saying have you guys
noticed the anecdotally
that your map programs are
malfunctioning in the last couple weeks
any of you guys had your your like
Google Maps or your ways I've just
noticed twice in the last two weeks from
two different drivers that I'm telling
you to go right and then make a circle
and then go back and then four it's like
yo this could be AI this could be a hack
this could be a though this is the long
War this is the way that China this is
the way that well first people you're is
anyone else reporting that these things
are I'm just wondering anecdotally if
you guys have experienced it because
it's happened to me two times and it
clicked like this is what the Chinese
would do to fight along where you
confuse and disorient the population if
ai's tracking do they turn right when we
tell them to turn right when they know
it's not then then they'll know like
okay so it's easy to manipulate this one
well yours it is you're right this is
but I'm not saying it's happening now
but your the strategy you're you're
saying is correct what they would do is
they uh our enemies whether it be China
or Russia or whoever would not disable
GPS
they would not disable Communications
GPS would be off by a degree they would
do things like that then we're less
likely to notice and then all of a
sudden our cruise missiles or whatever
hypersonics are missing their targets I
asked people on Twitter today and a lot
of them said yeah it was just so I
remember during uh occupy being on the
ground covering these protests you hear
this all the time even conservatives
start saying it in you know 2017 2018
when they started going out more and
being in large crowds that oh the feds
are jamming our cell phones they're
shutting our phones down so we can't
communicate and I'm like no dude you
don't understand
they're spying on you they want your
phones to work in fact they deploy
mobile cell units two high protests into
high traffic areas and protests to make
sure your phones don't go down because
they're spying and your phone went down
because there's too many people here and
the cell towers can't handle it people
don't understand they think our enemies
would disable GPS no that's ridiculous
they would spy on our GPS to track
everything we do they want us using
these things
yeah data is the new oil and data
harvesting getting information on people
also getting their DNA is something that
the Chinese government has been doing uh
in a very aggressive way the FBI a
couple years ago sent out a memo during
covid saying hey if you're taking a
covet test uh just make sure you're
disposing of the swab since there's been
Chinese government and Chinese
government-connected corporations taking
those swabs and then data harvesting DNA
from the American people in order to of
course not just game the big Pharma
system but more importantly also just
get the genetic information of the
American people which could potentially
be used for genetic bio weapons as we
know are also in progress and in the
works by the U.S pentagon just because I
already know those people who are going
to say looks a conspiracy theorist
here's the article from NPR China wants
your data and they already have it well
what data are you referring to your DNA
that's right as covid's cases begin to
rise a year ago Chinese company
contacted several U.S states and offered
to set up testing Labs as a byproduct
product the Chinese firm Beijing
genomics Institute would likely gain
access to the DNA of those tested you
know when I tell people that China's
stealing your DNA they go okay you're
insane so I don't say it that way I say
do you see that NPR article something
about a Chinese company taking covet
tests to get the DNA out of it and that
still sounds insane but don't worry I
just show them the article and say I
don't know man NPR is reporting it I
have a different approach I say China's
stealing your DNA the US government
already has it and is weaponizing it and
probably using it against you as we
speak right now should I not have done
the 23 in May no that information also
is being found to be sold on the black
market everything you if something is
free you are the product so every little
piece of information their data mining
the NSA the the US government major
servers and it's it's not just uh you
know your DNA it's also the keystrokes
it's also your heart rate it's also your
biometric data that's being collected
without your permission uh what are you
pointing at what are your wrists both of
you
specific but there's a specific strategy
that you implement where you don't give
your information off and you're someone
like uh you know you're someone like a
ligma uh Johnson right instead of uh
Luke kardowski yes company now let me
pause right there they don't care about
lucrutkowski's vitals they care about
the anonymized data when they say things
like we don't we don't take your
information or they say like we're going
to collect your information for
Diagnostic reasons but we do not attach
your identity to it it will be
randomized and no one will know who you
are what they do when they take your DNA
assuming they do they don't care your
name they're mapping populations they're
mapping characteristics and because so
many people have taken it upon
themselves even me I'm wearing a Garmin
watch which tracks Health they all do it
now I I actually I like the benefits I
get from it but I recognize all of us
are snowflakes in an avalanche when they
collect all this data they can
collectively see detrimental Health uh
uh circumstances they can also formulate
bio weapons using that data thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
on next time